Hi, I'm Beau Carnes with Free Code Camp. In
this tutorial that you're watching right now,
I'm going to show you how to create a discord
bot with Python that runs completely in the
cloud. You don't need to install anything on your
computer, and you don't need to pay anything to
host your bot. We're gonna use a number of tools,
including the discord API, some Python libraries,
and a cloud computing platform called repple
it you probably already know what discord is,
and what a discord bot is, since
you're watching this tutorial,
but just in case you don't let me give you a brief
overview. discord is an app used for real time
text chat, discord servers are set up by people
and generally are focused on a certain community.
Many groups and organizations have discord
servers for people to chat with each other.
A Discord server often has many channels,
which are different rooms that you can chat in.
A discord bot is a user in your Discord server
that is controlled by a program instead of a
person. You can code a discord bot to make it do
whatever you want. There are many things discord
bots are often used for. They can be used to chat,
respond to messages, manage servers, play music,
and more. You can also use web hooks with
a discord bot to do things like give real
time updates on a GitHub repository. The first
step for creating a discord bot is to make sure
you have a Discord server to add the bot to you
may already have one. But let me just show you
how to set one up really quick in case you don't
already have one. So you're going to have to go
to discord comm and log into Discord. And then you
just click the plus button here to add a server.
And I'll say for me and my friends, and I'll just
call it robot family server. Okay, let's create
that. And now we have our server. Okay, so before
we can code our bot using Python, and using the
discord API, we must first create a discord bot
account right within Discord. So you're going to
have to go to the discord developer portal. I'll
put the link in the description, but it's just
discord comm slash developers slash applications.
So once you're on the applications page, you're
going to click this new applications button. And
then we're going to create a name for it. This bot
is going to send friendly encouragements to people
from in Discord. So I'm going to call it encourage
bot. Okay, I'll create that. Okay, now I'm going
to go to the bot tab here. And then I am going to
click Add bot and say yes, do it. Okay, we'll keep
the default the default settings as a public bot,
and then we won't require the OAuth to grant
the code grant. So now the bot has been created.
The next step is to copy the bot token. Okay,
so I'll just click Copy to copy the token,
we're going to need that later. Now this token
is your bots password. So make sure not to
share it with anybody. It could allow someone to
log into your bot and do all sorts of bad things.
And it could even allow someone to mess with your
server. And also, you can obviously regenerate
the token if they accidentally get shared. So
now we have to invite the bot to our server,
we have the bot user, and we have
to get into our server. To do that,
we're going to have to create an invite URL
for it. So let's go to the off to tab here.
And now we're just gonna go to the scope section.
Since this is a bot, we'll just click Buy here.
Now we have to scroll down a little bit more and
go to the bot permissions section. So we'll choose
the permissions we want for the bot. Our bot
is going to be mainly used for text messages.
So we don't need a lot of permissions. So your
bot may do different things. But let's just
choose some of these here. Actually, we'll
do all of them on this line, except send TTS
messages. Now you do need to be careful with
this administrator permissions. If you give
your bot administrative permissions it has, it
will be able to control your server in ways that
you may not actually want. And then I guess the
last one we need to add is the view channels or
bots going to have to view the channels. So after
selecting the appropriate permissions, we'll click
the Copy button right here. And this will copy a
URL that can be used to add the bot to a server.
And I guess we'll also have to recopy the
back key, we copy the back key earlier,
but now it's been re copied with this URL. So
we'll have to come back later to get the back key.
But now let's just open up a new tab and I'm
going to go to this URL Okay, so now we have
to choose the server, we want to add the bot to
I'll choose robot family server, the only option,
but you will probably have more than more options.
So we'll click Continue. And we want to approve
that we want to do all these things, we want
to authorize the bot for all these things.
And I'm not a robot and the bot is authorized.
That means the bot has joined the server. So if
we actually go over into our server, we can see
encouraged bot just slid into the server. But also
you see over here that the bot is offline, it's
not going to be online till we write our Python
code that creates the bot and run the Python code.
And speaking of Python code, it's time to start
that. Now I said earlier that you don't have
to install anything, you don't have to use any
software except your web browser, we are going
to be creating the entire discord bot, right in
the cloud on replique. The website for replique
is our epl.it. And replique is an online ID
EA, that you can just use in your web browser.
So it makes it a lot easier to code things if
you don't have to install any special software
on your computer. And then you can log into
it from multiple browsers, multiple computers,
and then you can easily access your code and your
programs no matter what computer you're using.
So we're gonna make our button this and then
it will also be completely hosted in the cloud,
we can even run the bot on this website, so
we don't have to run it on our local computer.
And that will make it so we can keep the bot
running, even if our computer shuts down, or we're
gonna where we close the browser tab or anything
like that, I'll show you how to make the bot. So
it'll keep running in the background continuously.
And then you don't have to worry about it.
If you don't already have account, you're
going to sign up. But I'm going to log in here.
Okay, now that I'm logged in, and I
click this new repple in the corner here,
now we just have to create, choose the language
that we're going to use for this new repple. The
cool thing about repple it is that you can use
a bunch of different languages with it. And so
that makes it simple. If you're going to run some
of these languages on your computer, you probably
are going to have to install some extra software
or extra things on your computer to be able to run
these languages. But if you just go to repple, it,
you can just do it right in your browser. And you
don't have to install anything. But we're going
to be doing this in Python. So I'll click Python.
And it will have a default name here. But
I'm just going to be calling it encouraged.
Okay, and I'll just create the repple.
So let's go over the main part of Rep. What we
have here, which is right here is the code editor.
And you can see a default with a file open
called main.py. And we can type our Python
code right in here. And then here over here
are the files, and you can create new files,
we will be creating a few new files in the course
of creating this bot, you can also create new
folders. And then over here is the console. The
console is where the standard output will appear.
And you'll be prompted to enter input if
you're going to have input in your code.
And in Python, it's going to it's going to double
as an interactive prompt. So you can actually type
in Python code right here. And it will evaluate
the code interactively. So that's pretty cool. And
then over here, we have some things on the side
here. so files, version control, if you're going
to associate with git, and or we're not going
to do that in this tutorial, though. And then if
you're going to install packages, but there's also
another way to install patches that we'll see.
And then the main thing we're actually going to
be using is the replique database. So one thing
cool about replique is it includes a database
as part of it. And so you can easily store
things that will keep stored in there even if you
stop your program and run it again the everything
store in the database will will still be in there.
So we will be using that later in this tutorial.
And then you can also change some settings,
just like the theme of font size, all sorts
of stuff like that. But let's go back to the
files because we are going to start creating
our discord bot right now. So I mentioned that we
are going to be using the discord.py library. And
the first thing we're going to do is import that
library. So at the top has this do import Discord.
And the cool thing here is that in repple it it
will automatically install this dependency when
you press the Run button. So I mean my permanent
and do very much right now but if I click Run,
we'll see on the side here, that it's Installing
the discord despit dependency, and then it will
be able to use it in the program right away. So
there's nothing extra you have to do to install
dependencies besides just importing them right
in your program. So let me talk a little bit
about discord.pi. Before we continue with this bot
here, it revolves around the concept of events,
and event, it's something you listen to
and then respond to. For example, when a
message happens in discord, you will receive
an event about it that you can respond to it.
So let's make a bot that replies to a
specific message, we're going to start
with a very simple bot, and then we're going to
add to it and just add more features as we go.
So the simple bot that we're going to start
with the code is actually taken directly from
the discord.pi documentation. It's a really good
example of like the most basic bot you can make.
And like I said, then we'll continue to build on
that after we get this simple bot created. Okay,
so we got the discord library, imported. So
let's add some more lines here. So now we are
going to create an instance of a client. This
is the connection to Discord. So do a client
equals discord dot client. This is just part
of the discord.py library. Now, we are going
to use the client that event decorator to
register an event that looks like this.
So I remember I mentioned that this client
uses events to make it work. So this is how you
register an event. And this is an asynchronous
library discord, that pie. So things are done
with callbacks. a callback is a function
that is called when something else happens.
So in this code, where you're going to use
the unready event, so I'm going to put async.
def on ready. So this event is going to be called
when the bot is ready to start being used. And
when it's start, when it's ready, when the bot is
ready, we're going to do this print. And this is
going to print right to this console right here.
So when the bot is run and ready to be used,
it's going to print this to the console, it's
going to say we have logged in as and then we're
going to actually be able to get the username
that's logged in as, and this is how you do that.
So there's a few ways to do it.
But so this is taking the client,
this zero is being replaced with the client. So
it's doing the client that user So that's this
client, this zero gets replaced with this client
here as client, that user to get the username.
And to make sure I have this right next
to the quote goes here. And there we go.
Okay, let's create another event. So that's the
event that happens as soon as the bot is ready,
and it's working. So the next event is if it
receives a message, if the bot senses a message
right in the discord server. So it's going to
start off just the same to register the event.
And we're going to do another async
function. But this one is on message.
So these function names are specifically
from the discord.pi library, it's looking
for these function names, to know what
to do, when certain things happen.
This onmessage event triggers each time a message
is received. But we don't want to do anything if
the message is from ourselves, which is the
bot. If the message is from the bot, we want
to do nothing. And this event takes an argument
called message. Or you can call it anything you
want. But it's traditional to call a message
because it's the message that's being received.
So this event triggers each time a message is
received. But we don't want it to do anything.
If the message is from ourselves, we're gonna make
it check if the message is from ourselves. So if
message dot author equals client, that user
looks like I spelled something wrong there.
So if the author of the message is the user,
our bot user, all we're going to do is return.
Next thing we're going to do is we're going
to see if the message starts with a command
that's being sent to our discord bot. And we can
make up those commands to be anything we want.
So in this case, I'll show you we're going to
do if message dot content that starts starts
with and we're just going to make it up to be
dollar sign Hello. For our bot. We're going to say
all the commands are messages that start with the
dollar sign. So if the message starts With dollar
sign Hello, then the boss should know that
it's received a command so it should return
something. And to return a message
back to discord, we're going to await
message dot channel dot send. So this is going to
send a message to the channel. And the message is
going to be Hello. Okay, so now so whenever the
bot notices that someone says dollar sign Hello
within discord, it's going to respond Hello with
an exclamation point. So this is everything we
need for the bot. But we still have to run the
bot. So here's the line to run the bot client
dot run. And then right in the client that run
we need to put our token, we need to put our bots
token which is like the password for the bot.
Before we just go and copy the token again and
put it right in here, there's something I should
tell you about replica that you need to be careful
with. By default, all replicates are public,
they're visible to anyone. So anyone can just
access your replica. And they could potentially
see anything you put in your replica, including
any secrets or keys. And remember, I told you
that this key is like a password, you don't want
anybody else to find out about it. But there is a
way to keep things secret. And that is to use an
environment variable. So in repple, it let me show
you how you can use environment variables, we are
going to first of all, create a new file here. And
the new file is going to be called dot E and V.
So that anything we put in a dot E and V file will
not be made public, nobody will be able to see
anything in a dot E and V file in replique, pretty
much on a public account on a free tier account.
Everything is public always except just this one
file dot E and V, we're gonna put token equals,
and we're gonna set the token to equal our
token. Now we're gonna have to go back and
get our token. So let's go back to our development
portal page, the discord comm slash developers,
and then I'm gonna go to bot gonna copy the
token. And then we will go back over here. Okay,
there's my token. I'm going to disable
this bot later and change the token. So
don't bother trying to figure it out to use it
for your own code. But now that we have our token,
we have to make it so it gets into our main
file. So to do that, we are going to have to
do have another import statement here. So I'm
going to put import OS, and then down here,
we need to access that token from the dot EMB
file. So what we're going to put in our code here
is oh s dot get e and V. And then I'm going to
put token. Now the reason why it's token here
is because that's the name I put right here, you
can actually use any name for the token doesn't
have to be token, you just have to make sure that
when you're getting the environment variable,
you use the same name here. So now when you
run the code, it's just going to replace
this right here with your token. Now, if you're
doing this locally, or you're doing in such a
way where you know, nobody else is ever gonna see
this code, you can actually put your token right
in here. And you don't even have to import o 's
here. But since we're doing it in a public way,
we need to make sure that nobody else sees our
token, or else they could get access to our bot.
And that's actually it for our basic bot.
Like I said, we're going to add some more
additional features later. But let's run it now
and test this out. So click run here. Okay, look,
we have logged in as encouraged bot. Now let's go
to our server. You can see look before it showed
as logged out, but now it shows it as logged
in. So let me let's try this. I'll say hello.
Now you can see that's from from me, and it didn't
respond. Because remember, the special command is
actually dollar sign Hello. So let's try that.
And it works encouraged by just responded with
Hello. So our bot works if we do another command
like Hi, how are you or not not another command
another message? It's not going to respond at all.
But if we do the dollar sign Hello. Then it will
respond. So we just created a basic discord bot
that responds to the command dollar sign Hello.
And obviously you can make it any command. So if
you don't want to respond to dollar sign Hello,
you can actually use any command here. And then
you can change what it's going to respond with.
Now that we have our basic
bot working, we'll improve it.
I said it's called encouraged bot for a
reason, the bot will respond with a message
of encouragement. Whenever someone sends a
message containing a sad or depressing word,
we're gonna make it so anyone will be able to add
encouraging messages for the bot to use. And these
messages will be stored in a database. So they
will save even after you stop and start your bot.
We're also going to add another thing in the
database. That turns on whether that turns
on or off whether the bot is is responding to
messages. And an extra feature of encouragement
we're going to do is that the bot is going to
return a random inspirational quote from an API,
when someone types the message, dollar sign
inspire into the chat. So let's start with
that last thing I said, we're going to start
by adding the dollar sign spider feature.
I found this API called Zim quotes.io. That will
return inspirational quotes. Now, you can use any
API. So if you don't want to use in quotes.io,
you can just find a different one. If somehow
this isn't working, just try to find a different
API, but we're going to use is in quotes.io. And
a lot of these principles will apply to really
any API that you're using. So let's go back to
our bot. And we are going to import some new
things to work with this API. So what we're
going to do is we're going to import a couple more
Python modules, we're going to add a get quote
function. And we're going to update our bot code
to call the function. So let's import requests.
This request module allows your
code to make an HTTP request
to get data from the API. The API returns
JSON. So we're going to have to import
the JSON module. What because that's going to make
it easier to work with the data that's returned.
Okay, now we're going to add a
helper function. It's called get,
quote, this is a function we can call to return
a quote from the API. So first, we're going to
use the request module to request data from
the API URL. So that's going to go like this,
the response we're going to store the response
from the API in a variable called response.
And so we have to use the request module like
this request that get we're going to
make a get request to this URL. Now,
I just had to find this URL by looking at the
documentation of this in quotes API. So HTTP,
S, colon slash slash is in quotes.io. Slash API
slash random, it's going to return a random quote.
Okay, now we're going to convert that response
into JSON. So we're going to do JSON, data
equals JSON dot loads, response, that text. So
this response that text, I just had to look in
the documentation of the API, and found
out that the response is going to have
this response that text that I can, I can load
into JSON. So now we have to do something with
this JSON, we have to get the quote out of it.
Now, this was a lot of trial and error, I had to
print out the JSON data and try to figure out
how how to get the exact part of that JSON
that I needed. So so this is what what we
ended up with, quote, equals JSON data. Zero,
Q. Now, that's going to be the quote q stands for
a quote. And it's just something that's part of
this in quotes API, the result that's returned
from this API is going to have a key called q
when the value is going to be the quote.
So we're going to start with the quote,
but then we want to add after the quote,
the author of the quote who said it.
So I'm just going to add a plus we're going to
do some string concatenate Nathan here. And I'm
going to make it have a space after the quote,
and it's going to be a dash, the dash is going
to be right before the person's name. It's just a
way to kind of show who's who's doing the quote.
So we'll do another plus here. And let's go back
into the JSON data. And this time, instead of the
queue, we're going to do a for author. Okay, so we
got a quote in here. Now, I can return the quote.
Okay, now we have to update our bot. So it uses
this get, quote function to get a quote, and then
return the quote, as a message to Discord. Let
me scroll down a little bit here. So now I'm just
going to update these lines here. This was just an
example to rich to respond to the message Hello.
But that's not what our final bot is going to
do. So I'm going to change this to inspire.
And let's move this over a
little bit. So we can see more
of the code. So if the bot gets this message
inspire, we're going to send a quote. So
the way we're going to send a quote is first
adding another line. So I'm gonna put quote,
equals get, quote. So it's going to call the
get, quote, function and return the quote here.
And now I can just return the quote, or I can
send the quote to Discord. Okay, at this point, we
can run the code and try it out. If it's already
running, we got to stop it, and then run it again.
And then we have to wait till it says it's logged
as encouraged bot. That means we can go back to
our Discord server, and say, Hi, bot doesn't say
anything. Let's see if it will say, Hello, hello.
Okay, that command doesn't work anymore.
Because we change it. Let's do inspire. Okay,
we have an inspirational quote. And let's try
inspire a few more times to see if it's random.
There's another one. There's another
one. See, we're getting a random quote,
for every time we do it. So this is the quote part
by failing to prepare you are preparing to fail.
And then we add that the space and then the
dash, and then the author Benjamin Franklin.
Okay, well, that works. Let's go, go back to our
bytecode. Now we're going to implement the feature
where the bot responds with encouraging messages
when a user posts a message with a sad word.
So in this, this time, the user isn't putting a
certain command into discord to get a result. This
time, the bot is going to be checking every word
in every message to see if there's a sad word. And
if it's if it notices a sad word, it's going to
return an encouraging message. So the first thing
we're going to do is to create a Python list that
contains the sad words that the bot will respond
to. So right after the client variable is created,
I'm going to create another one called sad.
Words. And the CI word. This is just going to be
a list like I said, oops, there we go. depressed,
unhappy. Now I'm gonna have a list of
words here, you can add additional words.
Really, you can put any words you like on
this list here. I'll have a miserable. And
let's do one more. How about depressing? Okay, so
we are going to make it so whenever the bot sees
one of these words in the message, it's going to
respond. So what is the bot going to respond with?
Well, now we're going to add a list of encouraging
messages that the spot will respond with when it
sees one of those words. So I'm going to make a
new variable called starter and encouragements.
Now, I'll tell you why this is
called starter encouragements.
It's because these are the there's going
to be just a few encouragements that the
bat starts with, but users will be
able to add more encouragement later
that are stored in the database. So the start
encouragements I'm just gonna do a cheer up.
Hang in there.
And you are a great person, or maybe it's
just another bot. So we'll do person slash bot
Feel free to add any number of encourages you
like, and remember later, user will be able
to add more encouragements. Now we need to update
our bot to use the two lists that we just created.
So the first thing we're going to do is import the
random module, because the bot will be choosing
messages randomly. So import random. And we'll
be using this later the random module to make it
get the random message. So we're going to update
the on message response here, we're going to add
something on in this on message async function,
that's gonna check all the messages to see if
they contain a word from the sad words list. And
then if the sad word is found, the bot will send
a random message of encouragement. So here's the
code for that. After we check to see if it has
starts with inspire, then we're going to check
just if it has any other word from the sad word
list. So this is how we're gonna do if any, if any
weight, if any word in message for word and sad
words. So this just means it's going to go through
every word, and the sad words. And gonna see if
any of those words are in the message. If it sees
any of the word in the sad words in the message,
then it's going to Oh, wait. Message dot channel
dot send. This is just like this line above here.
And what is it going to send, it's going to send
random dot choice, it's going to choose a random
choice from starter encouragements from
that list that we created. Okay, we can
test the button Now, let's see if there's
something wrong here. undefined name message.
Okay, got it. I got ahead of myself
here. Actually, this message should be,
it's actually supposed to be message content
by switch to message, because since we're
going to be using message content a bunch
of times, what I want to do actually, is
create the message variable right here message
equals message content. And then anytime we
see message content, we can switch it with
message here. Okay, let's test the bot now.
Okay, let's go back over here. Let's
see if the Inspire still works.
Worked. Now let's check the sad word. I am sad.
You're a great person bet Brett person's
life spot. Well, now, I am depressed.
Hang in there. Oh, that's making me
that is making me feel much better.
Thanks. This encouraging by is very encouraging.
So it's working, it can now respond, whenever it
sees sees a stad method, it's going to try to
encourage the person that put that sad message.
So at this point, you basically
know enough to create your own bot.
But let's keep going because we're going to
add some more advanced features that I already
discussed. Now let's make it possible to update
the bot right from Discord. A user should be able
to add more encouraging messages for the bot to
use when it detects a sad word. Like I mentioned
before, we're going to use repple. It's built
in database to store user submitted messages.
This database is a key value store that's built
into every rebel. So let's add that to our code.
Now. Now, I showed you this before this tab here,
this the only really the only point of this tab
is to just show you the commands the
most common commands for the database.
And you don't actually need to get in from here
if you already know him because this type of men,
but let's go to the top of the code and we're
going to Alka just insert this so I inserted from
replique import dB. This allows us to use the
replicate database. Before we add new commands
for the bot. Let's add two helper functions that
the first one will be able to add custom messages
to the database. And the second helper function
will be used to delete messages from the database.
So let's go under the get quote function.
This new function is going to
be called update encouragements.
So that's gonna it's going to update
the encouragements in the database.
And it's going to accept an
encouraging message as an argument.
So first, it's going to check if encouragement
is a key in the database. So if encouragements
do that, right, encourage myths is in dB
keys. So DB keys just returns a list of
the keys in the database. So if increment
is already in the keys, it's going to get
those all the key all the incursions are
already in the database. encouragements
equals the way to get a value from the
database that stored under a certain
key is like this DB encouragements.
Okay, so we've gotten the encouragement.
Now we just have to add the new encouragement to
this list. So encouragements dot append that's
going to add something new to this list. And we're
going to type in the encouraging message, which is
the argument that was passed into this function.
And then after we append the new encouraging
message to the old encouraging messages, we
have to save it again into the database. So DB
encouragements equals
encouragements. Else, if there's not
already encouraged us in the database,
then we're going to have to
create it. So dB, encouragements
equals, and we're going to put a bracket
here because this is going to be a list,
but it's only going to have one message. And
the one message is the encouraging message
that was passed into this function. Okay,
so now, let's see what we did wrong up here.
Okay, that's supposed to be if encouragements
in dB key not is I just excellent typed an
essence of it in. So that's supposed to be in.
Okay, so now, we finished our helper function,
let's create a new one, which is to delete an
encouraging message. So def delete, encouragement.
And it's going to take an index, as is an
argument, the index of the message to delete.
So first, we need to get a list of the
messages from the database. So encouragement
equals dB. encouragement. So we got the
list of encouragement from the database.
Now we have to check if the length of
encouragement is more than the index, because
the person could pass in an index that's,
that's actually not in that that list.
The person could pass in an index that's actually
not part of the list. So if the length of
encouragements is more than the index, then we're
going to delete DLS. Delete. We're going to delete
the encouragements at that index. And finally,
we are going to save it into the database again
equals encouragements. And this can
actually be in this if statement.
Okay. Done. We can now add an
encouragement and delete and encouragement.
Now let's update our bot code to use these
functions. So users and discord can update
encouragements and delete encouragements,
right from Discord. Let's go down here.
So the first thing we're going to do, if you
remember, currently, it returns a choice from
the starter encouragements if it sees a sad word.
But we want to also be able to return a random we
want the random encouragement to also be able to
come from the database. So let's add some code to
be able to use the starter encouragements with any
encouragement that has been added to the database.
So first of all, I'm going to create a new
variable options equals starter encouragements.
Okay, so now, if there are if there's any
incursions in the data in the in the database,
if encourage meant in dB keys,
then we can, we can add those to the options. So
options equals options plus DB encouragements.
Okay, so now instead of picking from starter
encouragements, we're going to pick from options
of encouragement to return. Now we're
going to add some code to add a new
user submitted message to the database.
So it's going to be looking for a new,
a new command. So if the message
from discord starts with the command,
knew, if it starts with the command new, that
means it's going to be a new message to add to
the database. So the command that the bot is going
to be looking for is the command dollar sign new,
but then in the same message that you that the
user puts dollar sign new, they're going to put
a space, and then they're going to put the new
encouraging message. So we need to break off
the encouraging message from the the new command
because we don't want to add the new command to
the database, we just want whatever text comes
after the dollar sign new, whatever text that
the user submits, after DOS, I knew we want
to add that to the database. So let's do let's
get the encouraging message. And the couraging
message is going is going to equal message dot
split, we're going to split off the message
from New. So we're gonna do dollar sign new.
Okay, so we are now going to get an array of
the message that splits at New. And so we're
getting the second element in the array. And
that second element of the array is going to be
the new message. Now you can see that we're not
just splitting at New, we're splitting up new
space. So there's a space after that, because
we don't want the user is going to put dollar
side new space and then the message and we
don't want to add the space to the database.
We just want the message after the database
or after New. So we got the new encouraging
message. And now we just need to update the
encouragement with that new encouraging message.
Then we want to send something back to the user
so they know that it worked correctly. So wait
channel or message dot channel, dot send. New
and courage couraging message added. Oh, yeah,
that that should be and again, I don't know
why keep doing that. If incursions and DB keys.
Okay, now we'll add the ability
for a user to delete a message. So
a new function if message that starts with if
it starts with Dell, or delete, that's what Dell
stands for. That starts with Dell, we're going
to get the list of messages. encouragements or
we're not going to get the list of messages, we're
just going to actually just create an empty list
called encouragements, because we're going to want
to return the new list of encouragements later.
So we're going to start it started this with an
empty list. And we're going to check if there's
any encouragement already. So if there's
any encouragement already, in dB keys,
then we're going to delete one of them. First,
we have to get the index from the command. So
So if matches that starts with dollar sign,
delete. So if it starts with Dell, Dell, that
means delete. Then we're going to first create an
empty list. incur, we're going to create an eight
encouragements variable as an empty list that we
will add to in a second, if encouragements, we're
checking if the incursions are already in the
database. Because if there's no encourage us in
the database, and we don't want to try to delete
any of them, so if it's already, whoops, we'll see
if increments are in dB keys, then let's get the
index from the message that the user submitted
through Discord. So we have to get the index,
or you have to split it from from
the here. So message that split.
And just like before, we're going
to, it's going to look very similar
Dell. And this time, adding the space there is
optional. What let me show you what I meant.
So before we add a space here, this time, we don't
necessarily have to have a space because we are
going to convert it to an integer. So whether
there's a space or not, it will still correctly
convert to the integer, whatever not there, we're
going to type in a number, the user is going to
have a number after the command del, and it's
going to be converted to an integer in Python.
Now, we just need to delete the encouragement
that's at that index. And then finally, we need
to get a list of all the encouragements that
get the liver current list after it's
been deleted. Because we're going to
return that to the users so they can see
the updated list after it's been deleted.
And now we are going to send that back
a weight message dot channel dot send
encouragements. Okay, so the reason why we made an
empty list here is because if there, if there's no
encouragement in the database already, it's just
going to return the empty list here. But if there
is encouragements in the database, it will get
those encouragements and then return return those.
Okay, let's test this bot. And then
we'll add some a few extra features.
So I'm running the bot again.
Okay, the bots running and we will test
it. So let's test the other features first.
We still get an inspiring message.
Now let's try to add a new message.
You are amazing.
Okay, hi, just realized I made an error
way up here. database has no attribute key.
So that's what's the key with an S at the end.
So let's stop this again. Let's run this again.
That's why it's good to test frequently
to catch these, these mistakes like this.
Let's go back over here. Okay, now let's try
typing this again. Again, new, you are amazing.
New encouraging message added. Let's add another
one new way to go. That may not make sense based
on the message that the person put in to get that
message but that's okay. New, you are the best
coder in the world. Okay, now in order
to receive get one of these messages,
we mean we have to have some sad words. So I am
sad. Hang in there. We've already seen that one.
Let's just type in sad. Again. Way
to go. Now, way to go. That's one
of our new messages. So this was one of the
original messages, the starter encouragements,
but now we've received randomly one of
our new messages. I'm not sad anymore.
You are a great person bought. I'm depressed.
Well, I guess you have to spell it right.
Cheer up trying to see another new one.
You are amazing. That's another
new one that we put in there.
Okay, now let's see if we can delete a message.
So we should be able to delete a message with
doe. And let's just delete the
first one. So I'll just spend zero.
Now it's going to return the messages that
are left. Now just way to go and you are the
best coder in the world. It doesn't have a
me So that one was deleted. So that worked.
Right now the only way you can see all the
messages that are all the user submitted messages
is to delete one, it would be nice to be able to
see the user submitted messages without having to
delete one. So let's add some additional
features. Let's go back over to the bot.
So after adding the ability to get
a list of user submitted messages,
from right from discord, we're going to add
the ability to turn off and on whether the
bot responds to sad words. So you will be able
to actually update that right from discord,
whether it's going to be responding or not.
So we're going to kind of do all that at once.
First of all, we are going to create
a new key value pair in the database.
So right after the starter encouragements, we're
going to check if responding is in the database
yet. So this is gonna be a new key in the database
responding. If it's not in the database, db keys,
then we're going to add it. And it's
going to default it's going to start off
by being true respond, thing equals true.
And we do need to put a colon right here.
And now we only want to respond if this is true.
So down here, where it responds to words. That's
this whole section right here is when it's
is when it's responding to the sad word. So
I'm going to press tab here, because this is
all going to be inside an if statement. If
dB, we're going to get the value of the
responding key in the database responding.
So if that's true, then it will respond to the sad
words. If not, it won't respond to the sad words.
In a minute, we will add the
ability to update this value.
So let's go back before we add
the ability to update that value,
we're going to add the ability to list encouraging
messages. So if message that starts with
me, maybe like guess what the user command
is gonna be used, it's gonna be a list.
So if the user, the user types in list into
discord, then first of all we're going to get
we're going to make a empty list encouragements
equals an empty list because there may not be any
encouragements in the list yet. So we're going to
check if encouragements is in dB keys with an S.
Then encouragements, we're
going to add them we're going to
set the encouragements in the database to
the incursions, variable DB encouragements
and then we just have to return the
encouragements. So Oh, wait that message
or send the message to the channel. That send and
encouragements. Okay, now, users should be able
to get a list of the encouragements. Now we're
going to have the feature of changing whether
the bot is going to respond to sad words
or not. So if message that starts with risk
responding, quotation mark responding,
then we're going to get the value. So the idea
is that the user is going to put responding true
or responding false, if the discord message
that the bot is going to receive as a command.
So if a nano value, we're gonna get the value that
the user typed in, so is it true or false split
we're going to do just like before responding.
And again, we're going to put responding space
because we don't want this space right after
that. So we want the first element in that array,
which is the second the second element of the
array and index one. So we got the value. So now
if value dot lower, no matter if they typed
in lowercase or uppercase, we're going to
convert it to lowercase. So if it equals True,
then we're going to make sure that DB responding
equals true. And then let me scroll down
a little bit here. We're going to send
the message message back to Discord. Oh, wait.
Message dot channel dot send. Responding is on.
Okay, we're gonna have an else, I'm just gonna
copy this whole thing. So if valued at lower does
not equal true. I'll just change this to else.
We're actually making it so the person doesn't
actually have to type in false anything
but true will be assumed to be false. So
encouraging, responding is going to be set to
false. And it's going to say responding is off.
The code for the bot is complete.
This is all we're adding to the bot.
We're not quite done, though. We're
not quite done. We're going to test it.
And then I'm going to tell you
about one more very important
step. So let's try this. Let's go to back to
our bot. Oh, we have to run the bot again.
Okay, the bot is running. Hey,
bot. I am sad. Okay, it added that
now let's get a list of our messages.
Remember sent is stored in the database.
There should still be messages. Yep. See,
these are the messages messages we added before
the last time we ran our bot. But since it
stored in the database, they get stored dependent
between times that you've run your your code. So
let's add one. Oh, put add. Nice. I'm just nice.
Oh, I did that wrong. It's actually supposed to
be new. Make sure you type in the commands, right.
And let's list them again. Show is
nice. Now let's delete something delete
index one that should be the middle one. And Yep,
it shows them that we can even list them again.
Now let's see if we can change turn off and on
whether the body's responding. Let's confirm
that the bot is responding. I'm sad. Nice, huh?
Maybe it's saying nice because the data said it's
hard to tell with this bot. But let's see if we
can turn off the messages. So responding false.
If I type in sad, and it doesn't say anything,
if I type in depressed, it doesn't say anything.
But if I do responding, true.
Okay, let's do say I am depressed.
Okay, the bot thinks that's pretty nice. Now,
since we created the responding variable in the
database, it will save weather between times even
if you shut down your bot and rerun it, it will
still save whether it's supposed to be responding
or not. Okay, so technically, our bot is done,
but you don't want to stop now. Because if I close
my tab, the bot will just stop running. And then
it's not gonna work. If I close my browser, the
bots gonna stop running, it's not gonna work.
There is a workaround repple it will continue
running a web server even after the tab is closed.
Now this is not a web server. But we can
create one to run it at the same time as this.
But even a web server will only run
for up to an hour without any use. Oh,
here's the rep docs about the web servers. See
it says once deployed, the server will continue
to run in the background even after you close the
browser tab. The server will stay awake and active
until an hour after its last request after
which it will enter a sleeping stage.
So even if you have a web server web server
running, it will eventually stop running after an
hour after its last request. So if nobody's
using the disk or bottles have stopped working.
However, there is a way to make the bot
continually get requests so it never shuts down.
So actually rip rebel has announced that in
the future They will offer a paid plan that
allows code run continuously, no matter what
it will just never enter the sleeping sage.
But they don't offer that quite yet. It's
coming very soon, maybe it'll be available
by the time you see this video. But until that
is implemented, there is another way to keep
your bot running longer than an hour. And this
method even works with the free tier of replicas.
So to keep this bot running continuously,
we're going to use another free service called
uptime robot, up and rollback can be set to ping
the bots web server on replica every five minutes
with constant pings, the bot will never enter the
sleeping stage, and will just keep running. So we
have two more things to do to make sure our bot
is working as we want to make sure it's working
running continuously. We're going to create a web
server and repple it and set up uptime robot to
continuously ping the web server. Okay, creating
the web server is simpler than you may think. To
do it, we're going to create a new file, so
go to files and click the Add File button.
And this is just going to be called keep alive.pi.
Because the whole purpose of the web server
is to keep keep everything alive. Okay, I'm just
gonna paste in the code from the web server here.
It's pretty simple. Like I said, and it's not,
it's not really specifically important for the
bot, it's just a thing that we do in replique, to
make it keep going. So I will have a link to the
text of this web server right in the description
here. So you can just copy and paste it also.
But you can see it's not that long. So in
this code, we're going to import flask,
and we're going to use flask as the web server.
And it's going to return Hello, I'm alive to
anyone who visits the server, the server will run
on a separate thread from our bot, the server is
going to run on a separate thread from robot,
so they can both be running at the same time.
But the rest of this is not really relevant to our
bot, we just need the bot to run this web server.
So let's go back into main.pi. And then at the
top, we're going to have to import it. So from
keep alive, import, keep alive. And if you just
go back over here, that that it's importing this,
which is this is what runs our web server here. So
from it's going to import the web server, and then
we're going to go all the way to the bottom. And
right before the client runs, we're going to call
keep alive. And this will run our web server.
So if I stopped the bot and rerun the bot,
it's something different is going to happen
because of the bot because of the web server.
Okay, you can see a new window open right up here.
And this is our web server running and see
how it says Hello, I'm alive. That's from
our web server code where it says return Hello,
I'm alive. So whenever you go to the server,
it says Hello, I'm alive. Now the important
thing here is this URL. So this URL was created.
And this is the URL that we are going to ping from
uptime robot. So I'm going to copy this URL right
here. And then we're going to use it in the next
section. So now we need to set up uptime robot.
So the first step is to create a
free account, and then get logged in.
Okay, once you're logged into uptime robot,
just click add new monitor for the monitor type,
https and the friendly name, you can
name this anything we're gonna just put,
bought. And then for the URL, this is where
you paste in the URL that you copied all
over from repel repple it and the monitoring
interval we'll just leave this the same as
every five minutes. And then create,
monitor and then create monitor again
monitor created so I can close this. And
we should be able to see it right here.
Here it is. This is now going to ping our
bot every five minutes. So at this point,
it's going to be continuing, continuing
continue to run even after we close our tab
and even after an hour. Even if there's no
activity in discord, this bot will just run
continuously. Let's just try closing the
tab really quick. I'm just gonna copy this
URL, close a tab. Let's see if we
can just open the tab back up on here
and you can see it's still running
still running in this right here.
It could mean it is going to say something
like this every time it's pinged.
I don't know if that's from the ping
or not, or if it's just from reloading.
But we are now done. Now the bot will run
continuously, so people can always interact with
it on replicat. It's time for a bonus section, you
already know how to set up a Python bot and run
it continuously from repple it. Now I'm going
to show you how to set up another discord bot
to work with web hooks. We are going to connect
the bot to GitHub so that the bot will post a
message to your server whenever a certain GitHub
repository is updated. And for this GitHub bot,
you don't even need to code anything, or hosted
anywhere. Let me show you how it works. Okay,
to add this GitHub bot, we'll go to our server.
And then we'll go to the server settings here.
And then we'll click integrations. And
then there's web hooks create web hook.
And instead of calling it Captain Hook, I'm
going to name it. I'll name it GitHub. Okay,
and we'll put it in the general channel.
And then I'll just copy the webhook URL.
Okay, I'll make sure to save.
Okay, now I'm gonna go over to the GitHub
repo that I want to connect with this bot.
So I'm going to use the free code camp.org
GitHub repo. And then I'll go to Settings.
And then on the side here, it says web hooks.
Okay, now I'm going to click Add web hook.
And then I'm just going to paste in the URL that I
copied from Discord. Now here's an important part,
you can't just use the URL, you also have to
add something, I'm gonna add slash GitHub at
the end of the URL. And then for the content
type, I'll change it to application slash JSON,
and they'll scroll down. And for what
event should trigger the web hook,
I'm gonna do send me everything. Depending on what
you're trying to do, you may want to do just the
push event or select individual events. But I'm
gonna do everything. So I'll add the web hook.
And now I can go back right over
to my discord channel. If I wait,
we should start to see some events happening
on the from the Free Code Camp GitHub repo.
Let me go and just try to make an event
happen. I'll just unstarred star the repo.
And it worked. We just got a message
from the GitHub bot, new star added.
So now we've connected our bot
to GitHub through web hooks.
And the GitHub bot will post a message
whenever anything happens on the GitHub repo.
You can create bots to work with a lot of other
external services with web hooks. Okay, you've
reached the end of this tutorial. Now you've
prepared to go out and code your own discord bot.